—Okay.
Okay, we've got something to tell you—
... about a new way—
...to support Vox video.
But first, we want to tell you
a little bit
about what makes us... us.
When you get to the end of a video,
you see this.
All of these people make Vox video...
what it is.
First, you've got the producer.
The producer usually comes up with
the idea for the video.
We make phone calls.
We read research papers.
We watch also a lot of YouTube.
Pitches it.
Reports it out.
So we interviewed
20 different experts
to find the ideal candidate
for our debate video
on euthanasia policy in Canada.
This chart shows how many charts
I'm going to make for
the next video.
Is 500 charts too many?
I am...
I don't feel like I'm worthy to be
the charts guy.
Do you know what I mean, like—
I like to make them because I like them
as a communication tool.
But—
Writes the script.
and we're the ones that you're usually
hearing in the video.
And then—
I had ham and cheese croissant.
Okay, let me explain.
We also do the mic check sometimes.
And you don't want to waste
a good question on a mic check.
So ask them a fake question,
which is often...
what did you have for breakfast
that day?
Oatmeal cookies.
Overnight oats for breakfast.
Cinnamon toast.
Because I am a four year old.
How's the audio?
You'll often see a researcher.
I spend hours poring over research
and calling different experts, too.
To make sure that we're
not just relying
on what we find online
for a fact.
Sometimes when we need to
map something out for Vox Atlas
the information isn't easily accessible.
For all these maps
I spoke to dozens and dozens of experts...
to get every detail right.
Sometimes we'll know
something anecdotally
but we'll need evidence to back it up
and to show it on screen.
So for the video on Texas judges,
for example...
we had to track down court cases
experts and data to back up
what we're seeing.
Story editors make sure that
a video script makes sense
and that the entire story
is going to deliver a really solid explanation.
We ask questions,
we suggest rewrites
and generally we try to cut out
all the stuff that doesn't need to be there.
Then, there's the editor.
This is who builds the video in Adobe Premiere.
Assuming it doesn't—
Hmm. [Beep]
Assuming it doesn't crash.
He can jump cut that.
This part plays a huge role
in shaping how a video feels.
It's the difference between this...
[country-inspired song plays]
[singing] This here’s a song for
a truck driving mother—
And this...
[pensive, plucking string music]
Sound design makes archival
come to life.
It gives a voice to photos
and power to videos.
And with sound effects on our animations...
we can highlight every newspaper,
calculate any chart...
click every web page and make sure
every robot has the right...
[robotic beeping]
Sometimes it's just watching
a ton of archive footage
looking for the perfect shot
to match the VO.
The animators make the video come alive.
Starting with rough sketches
and refining with each
and every draft.
We are making it pretty
but we're also making it make sense.
This is how we animate a yellow highlight
in a couple of clicks.
When we have a video cut
we go through many, many rounds of notes
before we publish.
Our art director makes sure that
the visuals are on point.
Our researcher checks the facts again.
And this is where we really celebrate
every tiny catch.
Copy editors make sure we spell good.
And because we have multiple videos
in production every day.
These are all the people that keep it moving.
And last but not least, I get the video
ready for YouTube.
I make all the subtitles
[hey that’s me! right here!]
and then I read all your comments.
All of them.
[say hi in the comments below!]
And then there's you.
You support us every time
you watch one of our videos.
Now there's another way
you can support us.
And support our goal
of making sure that good journalism
that's also fun to watch
is never behind a paywall.
We keep our work here
for free.
So our journalism can be accessed
anywhere in the world.
We can see the impact of that choice
any time one of our videos
makes a difference.
Like the time one of our
COVID vaccine videos
was screened at a vaccine center
in Taiwan.
Or all the times that you tell us
our work has helped you understand
something better.
And when teachers let us know
that they've played our videos
in their classrooms.
You can go to vox.com/give-now
to make a contribution and
help keep all of this free.
And help us do more ambitious journalism for you.
Like, remember this video
about mysterious circles
in the Sahara?
“There they were.”
We spent the better part of a year
investigating this weird thing that
we found in Google Earth
and we actually figured it out.
“This is crazy.”
“This is so much more wild than I expected.”
We're making another one.
In about a week
I'm leaving for Uruguay to investigate
a strange forest
with a fascinating story behind it.
I'm looking for a crew
to shoot with me in Vietnam.
And we're trying to figure out what our next
fact-checked debate should cover.
I had a protein bar which is
not a good breakfast.
But you know, that's...
We also want to keep doing
more of the things
we know you love.
What's the history behind how
so many Vietnamese-Americans
cornered the nail business?
Why can't New York City solve
its embarrassing trash problem?
I'll be explaining how movies get made.
We’re gonna be looking at the Supreme Court
and the court system.
We’re going to looking at the state governments
or what's happening in state governments.
We're going to be looking at the election
that apparently is upcoming
and has very, very old candidates.
And I can't wait to make the next Atlas episodes
on Tibet and other places.
And we have so many stories
about science and the natural world
on the way.
Plus a bunch more beautiful animations
and interesting visual storytelling.
We're part of a bigger company
and our work is partly supported
by advertising
and sometimes grants...
but it's not enough to keep
this whole machine working.
We're turning to you.
No newsroom relies on only
one funding source.
Your support will go a long way
to help us make more Vox videos
and keep them free for all.
And as a special thank you to those
who make recurring contributions
you'll get access to video tutorials
a newsletter that takes you behind the scenes...
and Q&A with Vox journalists
from across our entire newsroom.
We've been doing this
for almost ten years now.
But there's still so much we want
to make for you.
So help keep our journalism top notch
and free for everyone
by becoming a Vox contributor.
You can go to vox.com/give-now.
Okay.
Bye!
I'm going to go.
I actually really do have to
get back to my edit.
[country-inspired music plays]
Thank you!
So are we done?
[yes, this is a country-inspired song for Mother’s day]
[you can find it on APM music, titled
“Happy Mothers Trukkin Day”]